after months of denial Iran has finally
admitted its supplied Russia with drones
but only before the war
plus
we give a limited number of drones to
Russia months before the Ukraine war we
agree with the Ukrainian foreign
minister that they submit to us any
evidence they have about Russia using
Iranian drones in Ukraine
the Ukrainian president accused Iran of
lying
we are shooting down at least 10 Iranian
drones daily while the Iranian regime
claims that it allegedly provided a few
of them before the start of the
full-scale invasion Only Yesterday 11
were destroyed if Iran continues to lie
about the obvious it means that the
world will make even more efforts to
investigate the terrorist cooperation
between the Russian and Iranian regimes
and what Russia pays Iran for such
cooperation
what we do know is Keith says drones
have been used to strike Ukraine's
cities and energy facilities adding to
the ever-growing number of Civilian
casualties
Anna sokova knows her brother is dead
she just doesn't know where his body is
but giving a DNA sample at this mobile
laboratory she hopes to be one step
closer to resolving her anguish when
Russian troops occupied isium the
casualties were put in a mass burial
site many with just numbers to identify
them
we were not allowed to enter the
gravesite the military were there and
guarded the gravesite we were not
allowed there I know only the number of
the Grave we thought that everything
would calm down and then we would go
there and find his grave tidy it up but
we couldn't
I know he's not the only bereaved
relative searching for answers these
photos are all that is left of the
victims from the missile attack on this
apartment Block in life and in death the
couple were together
there was nothing left of the bodies the
concrete slab fell on them there was a
couple that was hugging they probably
felt that was coming that's how they
were identified because only they could
be hugging
all eyes are now on the front lines the
ukrainians say they've taken a village
in her son moving one step closer to the
regional Capital
pro-russian authorities in her son say
that they have seen the escalation in
artillery shelling over the last week
but say the front lines remain the same
but what we do know is that her Salon is
very important to the Russians it's the
only Regional Capital they've managed to
take since the start of the war and the
Ukrainian military believe they won't
want to give it up without a fight
foreign